good morning do you see that yellow 14
foot clearance sign well three days ago
those 14 foot waters you talked about
rose that high now the waters keep
receding this debris mark is one measure
of that and the flooding on this
downtown street actually went on another
hundred yards but major challenges here
have yet to go away although the rains
have stopped much of Houston looks less
like a major city and more like a swamp
the life-saving missions go on Border
Patrol agents rescued this woman found
clinging to a utility pole I'll push you
up right is the chief executive of
Harris County which includes Houston he
told us he has no clearer sense of how
many people are still missing there
could still be some people in some
vehicles that we haven't recovered yet
deputies found the bodies of an elderly
couple and their four
great-grandchildren they drowned in this
fan trying to escape the floodwaters
it's a swept the van back and it just
got him back but it was under at least 4
feet of water so it was invisible at the
time Harvey dumped a trillion gallons of
rain on Harris County enough water to go
over Niagara Falls for 15 days roughly a
third of the county some 450 square
miles is submerged 32,000 people have
been forced into shelters euston has
opened three major shelters that can
house up to 20,000 people officials vow
to keep them open as long as necessary
we need to make sure we have plans what
are we gonna do about housing what are
we gonna do about schools what are we
gonna do about infrastructure the
recovery is not going to be weeks it's
not going to be months it's likely to be
years FEMA has already received more
than 200,000 individual applications for
financial health and the overall
operation here is now down shifting from
rescue to recovery from life-threatening
to getting life back to normal
thank you Mark